President Trump has changed his story
about a highly scrutinized campaign
meeting involving his son and a Russian
lawyer the president acknowledged on
Twitter that it was a meeting to get
information on an opponent more than a
year after claiming it was about
adoptions vici Jiang is near the
president's New Jersey Golf Club where
he's on vacation we do good morning
oh good morning bianna an to everybody
special counsel Robert molar is
examining that 2016 Trump Tower meeting
as part of the Russia investigation and
you're right with that tweet yesterday
the president is publicly shifting his
explanation for the purpose of the
meeting over time facts developed
president Trump's attorney Jay Sekulow
seemed to acknowledge the White House's
changing defense of the 2016 Trump Tower
meeting between Trump campaign officials
and a Russian lawyer the question is
what law statute a ruler regulations
been violated and nobody's pointed to
one on Sunday the president pushed the
issue back into the spotlight in a tweet
he defended his son Donald Trump Jr's
involvement saying this was a meeting to
get information on an opponent totally
legal and done all the time in politics
and it went nowhere I did not know about
it then quickly went on to you know a
story about Russian adoption and how we
could possibly help but politics weren't
mentioned in Donald Trump Junior's
initial statement about the meeting in
July 2017 only later did he admit he
took the meeting because he was promised
dirt on Hillary Clinton in retrospect I
probably would have done things a little
differently again this is before the
Russia mania this is before they were
building it up in the press for me this
was opposition research in January the
Trump legal team revealed in a letter to
the special counsel that it was
President Trump himself who dictated the
explanation about adoption which
contradicted previous White House
statements about the president's
involvement this was Donald Trump jr.
and his lawyers the president was not
involved in that he certainly didn't
dictate but you know he like I said keep
wait and offered suggestion like any
father would do
the seculow insisted that even though
the public account of that meeting has
changed the information the legal team
has given the special counsel has been
very clear legal experts have said that
criminal charges linked to conspiracy
are a possibility for the president's
son
but Sekulow says he is not aware that
Trumpy jr. is a target in this
investigation
Vlad all right so lots of questions
there we judge Aang thank you very much